Macy Gray goes on Pierce Morgan's show
why I don't know I didn't know I know if
she has a new album coming out or what
and she says something controversial
she says they're talking about gender
they're talking about gender identity
pronouns all that stuff she says I will
say this and everybody's going to hate
me uh-oh but as a woman just because you
go change your parts doesn't make you a
woman
sorry okay
she continued if you want me to call you
a her I will because that's what you
want but that doesn't make you a woman
just because I call you with her and
just because you got a surgery all right
so that happens Adam and audience
there's a firestorm of course everyone's
like oh my God she's transphobic bigot
you know everybody's screaming there you
know how they vomit their words out
so then she decides four days later
three days later to go on NBC Today with
Hoda and I see this interview and it's
just insufferable in every possible way
right there it is you can see and
suddenly she's singing a different tune
I see Hoda that's kind of like is there
anything that you you want to talk about
you know they're trying to get her to do
the walk back we talked about the
Hollywood Walk back yesterday and here's
what she says I've learned a lot through
this so I think that was one of the
reasons that it happened it was a huge
learning experience for me you can call
yourself whoever you believe you are
there was like music playing in the
background where there needed to be and
nobody can dictate that for you or take
that away from you
she goes on
being a woman is a Vibe and it's
something I'm very proud of and
something that's very precious to me I
think if you and your heart feel that's
what you are then that's what you are
regardless of what anybody says or
things so Adam my blood was boiling a
little bit on this one here's why
first of all she said something that was
she gave her opinion she came out
why didn't she just leave it at that
she's got a platform why do none of
these celebrities have a backbone why
can't they just say something that's how
they feel and that's it why is it that
the second everybody comes out and has a
problem with it they're going to do the
walk back so I see this and I get peeped
tell me how you feel about this
Hollywood what happens here and gender
wow that's a pack question yeah well
um good for Macy Gray for getting to the
headlines again because I haven't heard
of her name in well that is true how
long
so like singing her song before the show
I tried out
like uh wasn't she in Training Day as
like a crackhead I don't know but uh
Tyler told us she was in Spider-Man
apparently Spider-Man but look
I feel like the whole trans thing is
just such low hanging fruit I mean do
you have any trans friends no I don't
have any trans friends I know they're
out there yeah I'm not transphobic you
know phobic phobia means you're you hate
something right or you're prejudiced
against something
I don't like nobody wakes up like I hate
these trans folks like right I don't
know anyone thinks like that I think to
our friends in the trans Community I
think people are unclear as to what's
going on you're a he or a she you're a
day you're uh why can't you just say
like why is it criminal now to just come
out and be like a man is a man a woman
is a woman biology is biology these
things have you could feel however you
want to feel but it doesn't change
reality well it depends like what you
mean by criminal like nobody's going to
jail over words people get de-platformed
people get I mean look at her she was
afraid her career was going to be
complete why did she come and walk that
back because she probably had threats
against her she probably felt like oh
I'm not going to get booked on this on
that I'm going to have no career after
this so they fear career destruction and
it happens to people even on Twitter
they get totally deep platformed yeah
they pull the Rogue out rug out for
monitor them so we're in a time now
where you can't just say you can't just
say something go out there even if she
felt that way and you don't like it why
why does nobody well there's look the
woke mob I I would assume a lot of the
trans folks
are kind of
classified under woke mob I think that's
fair to say yeah and look they're pissed
they got loud voices the the whole you
know what though it's about what just
mad why can't you just wake up and be
mad every day they're mad I'm Italian
it's possible they're just waking up oh
I gotta go to war with somebody someone
said something I mean look what happened
with Dave Chappelle Dave Chappelle had a
trans friend a trans comedian and he
says he said he had a great joke he's
like We Care like you told a whole trans
joke and they go be careful Dave they
gonna come after you and he goes well is
it one day or multiple days yeah these
days there's so many like you hear
things on Twitter you know 10 people
spouting off they're mad and
corporations will just crumble because
some people are upset look
but how do you feel let me but you I
want to get to that you're you're a guy
who I I see as I could be wrong but it's
like Live and Let Live right and that's
how I think most people are it's like do
what you want call yourself what you
want but that doesn't change reality and
I think what bothers people is that now
this went from a conversation about
acceptance to a conversation about now
we have to say there's no such thing as
a boy and a girl so are we in crazy town
now like why do we need to cater to the
crazy
because they demand it wow yeah I don't
I don't even know if it's like catering
to crazy it's just this is their life
and you're you're they feel that if
you're coming after them and I'm not
defending them but if they feel like
you're attacking them they're gonna
Strike Back like Trump says if you hit
me I'm gonna punch back ten times harder
not to get all political but you ask for
my opinion I'm gonna tell you two
stories about my trans experience it's
not going to be that juicy for something
that's not gonna come born and raised in
Miami
there we go yeah so I reached down I
reached out I said
um you gotta come to the podcast bring
some juice I'm gonna give you two juicy
stories cut this up number one
um I live in South Beach there's a place
on so you know Ocean Drive if you're
familiar with it it's you know if you
ever go to South Beach Ocean Drive
there's a I don't I couldn't tell you
the name because I never go but I walk
by it all the time it's on Ocean Drive
and on Sundays like I'll go ride my bike
go work out go to the beach hang with a
girl whatever
and there's like a pop in place of drag
queens yeah it's going off and Taurus
Galore and
just to give you some context I I'll
ride my bike by look at what's going on
and you know salute and keep it moving
and that's what I think most people
should do symbolically you're cool you
got your trans thing going on cool do
you guys I'm gonna go live my life right
and I think that's what most people are
doing now where transphobic comes in
which I'm not is if I if I'm on a bike
ride let's say if I stop my bike and I
go [ __ ] you you trans like now that is
wrong right but there's nothing wrong
with saying all right cool you guys do
your thing I'm just gonna
more power to you and the place is
packed people want to see it see that's
what most people are saying but the
problem arises and I'm glad you teed
this up for me
because the problem arises when facts
cease to matter there's people you there
has to be something has to be grounded
in reality here otherwise I could walk
in here and say well Adam I'm a kitten
meow meow meow
I pair at home I could bring it to the
show we talk about that all the time
Adam's like what look at that face I was
like no but listen I could come in here
and say whatever I want then and you
have to be obliged to say well yes
because Judd said that we all that's
just not how the world works now the
world does work that you can call
yourself a cat if you want to but that
doesn't mean you're a cat and people who
say you're not a cat have to be able to
say that in peace let me just let me
bring an example to you I read this in
the Daily Mail I coupled this with this
one Oregon mom blasts woke new state law
calling for free tampons and all boys
school bathrooms apparently now it's a
law it's called the menstrual dignity
act audience you rolling your eyes at
home I'm just asking menstrual dignity
act and it's a lot of money it's costing
you'll love this conversation it's about
money to pay for the dispensers about
5.6 million dollars would be diverted
from the state schools fund enough to
pay 30 teachers salaries for two years
and they're putting them in boys
bathrooms because you know it's part of
catering to children who are transgender
and non-binary
kindergartners yeah so they have tampons
that are being put in boys bathrooms now
now this is what I'm saying the reason
that I brought this up is because this
went from a debate about what you're
saying which is I drive past you know
there's a drag queens having a party
great you do you all cool like whatever
to now
tampons and boys back why do boys need
tampons two boys need tampons in your
opinion as you're saying I'm like is
this an onion headline no no this is a
Babylon bee no this is from no daily
this is from The Daily Mail and this is
happening this is a law in Oregon this
is Oregon we shouldn't Oregon well there
you go Oregon is the is the one state in
the country I don't know if you know
that that legalized or decriminalized
all drugs yeah you go to Oregon you have
time in your life
I do kind of think they should keep
tampons out of little boy's hands but
maybe that's an Oregon thing look but do
you see what you're saying you're saying
well maybe that's an Oregon thing but
this is batshit crazy right so we have
and you know we need Tampa if Macy Gray
went on television on Pierce Morgan and
said oh I wrote this article the other
day and this was batshit crazy she'd be
shunned she'd be de-platform she so this
is the world we're living in
so I I don't know what to say about you
know how did we get here and how do you
fix it how do you go back to the Live
and Let Live normal people who can say a
fact is a fact
and get away from tampons in
kindergarten boys and bathrooms so like
the whole
we're kind of bringing together Trends
uh
you know Crazy Town yeah cancel culture
right you know apologizing nothing wrong
with being trans you want to be trans I
don't care if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here